et puis en ce qui concerne la pêche
illégale merci beaucoup de mentionner
aussi ce sujet parce que c'est un sujet
qui est crucial parce que la surpêche et
surtout la pêche illégale et le premier
facteur de baisse de la ressource et de
la de l'effondrement du stock d'un
certain nombre de de euh de de poisson
et donc sur ça depuis
2020 particulièrement et Annie
gerérardin avait commencé le travail et
je le remercie euh également nous avons
euh euh et le président de la République
a fait de ce sujet une priorité en terme
de stratégie maritime dans les G7 des
deux dernières années nous avons porté
le sujet et ça a porté ses fruits
puisque pour la première fois au G7 au
Japon il y a eu une mention spéciale sur
le l'enjeu de faire de la lutte contre
la pêche illégale et il les cite un
enjeu prioritaire de tous les pays du G7
et donc j'organiserai à la suite de ce
G7 une réunion ministérielle avec tous
les ministres de ce G7 pour mettre en
œuvre la décision politique de haut
niveau qui a été porté par les
différents sèes d'État et de
gouvernement première chose deème
élément la France a rejoint
euh l'Alliance internationale contre la
pêche illégale je vous passe le le titre
en anglais c'est iuu c'està dire qu' y
une alliance qui permet de de mettre en
commun C nombre de moyens des données et
qui vise et bien à à à accélérer
l'action collective sur le sujet ensuite
nous avons demandé à la Commission
européenne de pleinement se saisir de ce
sujet j'en ai parlé encore lundi avec le
commissaire sivichus il faut que l'Union
européenne utilise ses cartons jaunes et
ses cartons rouges vis-à-vis de
paystiers qui ne respectent pas leurs
obligations en matière de lutte contre
la pêche éégale je vous donne l'exemple
de guyan parceque j'y suis allé il y a 4
mois 90 % des tortues Lutes ont été
massacré c'est le terme de le dire du
fait de la pêche illégale par des pays
que je ne citerai pas mais je cité le
enfin c'est en tout cas par des pêcheurs
illégaux brésiliens et des pêcheurs
ilgau du Surinam on a des actions de
coopération de commerce de développement
avec ces pays moi ce que je demande
c'est que à partir du moment où il y a
des activités illégales qui se déroulent
sur notre territoire par ces pays-tiers
il faut que l'Union européenne prennent
pleinement les sanctions et jouent sur
d'autres leviers aide commerce
financement pour faire reculer cette
pêcheigale ça fonctionne notamment
vis-à-vis des pêcheures illégaux
brésiliens puisqu'il y a eu des actions
très fortes coup de point de la part de
la marine française pour éloigner les
pêcheurs illégaux brésiliens et donc du
Pacifique et vous avez évoqué un certain
nombre de pays en passant par les
Caraïbes et l'Océan Indien l'action de
la France elle est résolu et nous allons
mener des des actions de coopération
entre nos marines européennes et les
marines de C payslin pour aussi et bien
renforcer la sécurité maritime et
renforcer la souveraineté de nos euh de
nos eaux et et surtout préserver aussi
la viabilité et la les ressources dans
nos pays donc ça à plusieurs niveaux au
niveau multilatéral G7 au niveau
européen on demande à ce que la
Commission européenne prenne ses
responsabilités et au niveau aussi
national en terme de coopération nous
menons une lutte acharnée et nous aurons
au cours de la prochaine année aussi
avoir un travail très fin à faire sur
les closes miroir c'est ce que je vous
disais c'est c'est-à-dire que il faut
qu'on arrive à mieux identifier quels
sont les produits qui viennent dans nos
assiettes qui pourraent être issu de
pêche illégale et je crois que Pierre
kliskin le député européen a fait un
premier rapport sur le sujet et donc il
faut qu'on on accélère le le le le
travail en en la matière parce que en
plus la pêche illégale est en général
faite avec des conditions sociales et
d'emploi des des des de de de de
personnes de marins qui sont des
conditions dignes de l'esclavagisme donc
il a aussi un enjeu social aulà d'être
un enjeu de sécurité et d'ê un enjeu
environnemental